In November of 1983, The Demogorgon was banished
from Hawkins, and during Christmas of that year,
12 year old William Byers coughed up a strange
slug that disappeared down the drain of his sink.
The creatures of the Upside-Down would not
be finished with this small town quite yet.
A new form of the Demogorgon coined as the demodog
has been growing its ranks in the shadows.
Because the demodogs operate using a hivemind,
they’re able to dig a series of tunnels underneath
the town. Despite their mental connection, one
of them manages to distance itself from the rest
of the pack and even form a bond with one of
the humans. To dive into the hive and see how
the demodogs’ pack really works, and what made
D’Artagnan an occasional exception
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Scentbird.
(metal music)
It’s Halloween in 1984 and the kids of
Hawkins, Indiana are not missing out on
their trick-or-treating, but 13-year
old Dustin Henderson finds the most
surprising treat of the night in his trash can
foraging for food. After bringing the small,
slimy creature inside, he believes
he’s discovered a species of pollywog;
a tadpole that he expects to
grow into some kind of amphibian.
I’ll call this stage one of the creature’s
metamorphosis, and just for fun, I’ll give
it a nickname: the demowog. Physically, it
looks like a slimy frog with an extended tail.
He tries feeding it a few pieces of his 3
Musketeers bar and discovers that the creature
doesn’t like the heat lamp in the tortoise
tank he’s keeping it in. It hides in the
shade until Dustin turns the heat lamp off,
at which point it goes to munch on the candy.
Because it takes a liking to this chocolate
bar, Dustin names it D’Artagnan after the
protagonist of The Three Musketeers novel,
D’Artagnan, but mostly just
refers to it as “Dart” for short. We
don’t know if Dart is male or female,
or if it just doesn’t doesn’t have a gender like
Mewtwo, but Dustin seems to think it’s a dude.
– I gotcha little guy.
– It’s not yet known if this is a
result of digesting the chocolate
or part of its metamorphosis, but that evening,
Dart has some kind of violent stomach ache
that includes something moving around in
it’s abdomen if you can call it that,
that causes it to screech out in pain.
(screech)
Dustin brings Dart to school the next day,
Thursday, November 1st, in his homemade
Ghostbusters trap, and convinces his friends to
join him in the A.V. room to see his discovery.
During class, Dart rumbles around in
its case and makes noises reminiscent
of a stomach growl. That afternoon,
everyone takes a turn holding Dart.
– Uh, he’s like a living booger!
– I say the same thing every time someone touches
me in LA. They theorize that Dart is a pollywog,
but he only seems to resemble species from
India and South America. Mike notices what
looks to be something moving inside of it
and moves the light to get a better look.
Dart doesn’t appreciate the direct light and
freaks out. The sound of the screech he makes
causes Will to remember the Upside-Down
and the moment he spit out a potentially
smaller version of Dart a year ago.
Unlike the known species of pollywog,
which are cold blooded, Dart doesn’t like light
or heat, so believing he discovered a new species;
Dustin and the group decide to show
their science teacher Mr. Clarke.
However after Will reveals to Mike that
he believes Dart is from the Upside-Down,
they rush to stop Dustin before
he gets Mr. Clarke involved
(since they made a pact with Hawkins Lab the
previous year that they’d keep all the stuff
about the Upside-Down a secret). They quickly
bring the container back to the A.V. room.
Dart rages inside of the box, causing
the whole thing to shake violently.
Mike readies a heavy microphone ready in case
it attacks and Dustin releases the doors.
Instead of attacking, it screeches while its skin
ripples. A pair of hindlegs burst from
its sides with a splattering of slime.
[CLIP]
It would appear that the agonizing sounds it
had been making had less to do with it being
hungry and more to do with growing pains from
the metamorphosis. The movement they had seen
around it’s abdomen area was most likely the
creature trying to kick out it’s hind legs to
be able to move more effectively. We’ll call this
stage 2: the demofrog. Dart runs out the door and
away from the danger it sensed in the room. Then
Dustin tackles his friend Max for no reason. LOL.
Dart ends up hiding in the back corner
of a bathroom stall. Will finds it first,
but Dart’s screeching gives Will a little
bit of Upside-Down PTSD. Once the door shuts,
Dart moves behind the toilet until Dustin
arrives doing his best Randall Boggs.
[CLIP]
It would appear that Dustin was right about
the trust shared between himself and Dart,
because when he finds him, Dart is willing to
hop into Dustin’s hands and hide under his hat.
After being returned to the safety of Dustin’s
turtle tank, Dart goes to town on some more
3 Musketeers before falling asleep for the
night. Deciding Dart would be safer at home,
Dustin leaves him in the turtle tank while
he goes to school the next day. Now, either
Dustin didn’t see Gremlins, or forgot the rules
about feeding strange creatures late at night,
because he returns home to find the tank
broken and with some kind of molted skin
or membrane dripping in slime left inside.
It’s strange that Dustin doesn’t seem to notice
the immediate parallels between his own situation
with Dart and what goes on with Gizmo, the
titular Gremlin of Gremlins, late at night.
Maybe he somehow missed Gremlins being in theaters
back in August because he went away to camp during
the summer. Or he let his joy over discovering
a slimy a new friend cloud his judgement.
Dart grows into stage 3: the demohog.
Not because it looks like a hog,
but more because he’s hogging up
all the food... Like Dustin’s cat.
Will and Mike had previously shared their worries
about Dart being a creature from the Upside Down,
and this is basically confirmed here.when
Dart’s face opens up just like the Demogorgon
from a year ago, canine teeth included. This is
also confirmed by the VFX team for the show.
The maturation rate of Dart shows how quickly
the demodogs can increase their numbers by
using a molting process that may or may not be
sped up by eating certain foods. Perhaps Dustin
realizes that as he comes up with a plan to trap
Dart. Using a classic trail of bologna slice,
he lures the creature outside and yeets him
into the cellar. That could have gone so badly.
– What gives you the right? What is
the difference between you and me?
– [Dart with Batman voice] I’m not wearing hockey pads.
What makes this interesting is that
it’s the first time we see a creature
from the Upside-Down outside during
daylight hours. It’s also a sunny day,
which should deter Dart from leaving the
safety of the indoors. Maybe it’s a plot hole,
or maybe there’s something that makes
Dart special in this stage 3 form.
– [Dart with Frieza voice] You have the esteemed privilege of
being the first to see my next form!
Locked in the cellar, Dart molts again.
Stage 4, as we know, is the demodog.
– Demodogs?
– [Dustin] Demogorgon. Dogs. Demodogs.”
– With a stronger set of claws
that come with this new form,
Dart manages to find a weak spot to dismantle
a corner of the wall. Once it reaches the soil,
it’s able to dig an escape tunnel until it reaches
the tunnel system all underneath Hawkins. These
tunnels are used by the demodogs to travel while
staying out of both the sun and the public eye.
The best example of how travel efficient these
tunnels can be is showcased when Dustin and
Steve Harrington are joined by Lucas and Max at
the junkyard to help lure Dart out and take care
of it. Dart appears after night has settled in
and a fog has rolled across the area. But Dart
will not fall for the same trick twice, it doesn’t
move towards the pile of meat they have set up.
Steve believes Dart wants a different kind of
entrée, one seasoned with “faberge organics”
and steps out of the reinforced bus to try and
provoke Dart to go after him. Little does he know,
Dart is simply a decoy while other demodogs
surround Steve and the bus for an ambush.
–  [Dart with Michael Scott voice] Well, well, well. How the turntables...
– [Zac] Outnumbering Steve, the demodogs
pounce towards their next meal.
(impact)
Stranger Things' heroes have changed a lot
over the years, but that doesn't change
the fact that they started off as a bunch of
basement dwelling dungeons and dragons fans.
They don't really cover this in the show... but
you know that at some point they had to address
the smell. That's why I'm partnering with
ScentBird as the sponsor of today's video.
Scentbird is reimagining everything about
the experience of buying fragrances.
Whether you're just getting started with
fragrances, or building your collection,
Scentbird acts as a place to express
yourself and discover your style.
Scentbird lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month, for just $17.
Every month you get to pick what you want
to receive so there are no surprises. They
have perfumes, colognes and a lot of unisex
options. With each fragrance, you’ll get a 30-day
supply so you can try out fragrances without
committing to an expensive full-size bottle.
But it goes beyond just sampling different scents.
Try their online quiz to help you
discover your olfactic identity.
The scents I received this month were
Sage Supreme, Bentley Silverlake,
and Commodity Book. I can see why
there's a reason people love the
new car smell. It's very energizing
and has the aura of cleanliness.
Don't let yourself smell like basement pizza! Make
sure to use my Coupon Code CZSWORLD for 55%
OFF at Scentbird.com. It’s just
over $7 for your first month!
Available in the USA and Cananda.
(ominous music)
Inches away from the razor-sharp
claws of a ferocious pack of dogs…
– [Dustin] Demodogs.
– I’m sorry, what?
– I said demodogs. Like demogorgon and
dogs. You put them together. Sound pretty badass.
– Inches away from the razor-sharp claws of a
ferocious pack of DEMOdogs, Steve makes a run for
it. Demodogs pounce at him from all directions,
and one of them ends up on the wrong end of
Steve’s best Ryne Sandberg impersonation. We’re
in the 80s, had to go 80s for that reference.
Steve gets to safety, but one of the dogs jumps
onto the roof of the bus and almost gets inside,
but gets distracted by the call of another
demodog, or possibly something greater.
More on that later. It’s possible that
this demodog on top of the bus was Dart,
based on the yellow spots seen on the
tail, but it’s hard to tell for sure.
If that is Dart, maybe it took pity
after seeing Dustin in the bus.
It joins the rest of the hunting party and leaves
to follow the call of another one of its kind.
What we can learn about the species from this, is
that the demodogs hunt in packs like lions and…
the raptors in Jurassic Park.
Once they have their target,
they lunge forward, teeth-first. Like
most life forms from the Upside-Down,
it would appear that the demodogs are almost
like a remix of many creatures from our world.
Dart’s may have been called away because of what
was happening at the Hawkins Lab, where a group
of scientists trying to enter the Upside Down were
massacred by the pack. One demodog appears from a
hole in the floor and tries bashing the protective
glass, but unlike Pennywise’s face that one time,
it fails to get through, so it lets out a
wolflife howl, inviting the others join it.
This signal is what lured Dart and his party
away from the junkyard. As a group, they’re able
to make some progress on the glass barrier.
The entire pack of demodogs invade the lab
sending Chief Hopper and a group of scientists
running for their lives. As a pack, they’re able
to sync up their attack patterns. For example,
three of them tackling at once is enough to rip
down a steel door, allowing them to claim their
prize and chow down on a group of scientists.
Despite the fact that most of the demodogs’
only exposure to the Rightside-Up is limited
to the underground tunnel network, they still
seem to have no problem navigating the halls
of the Hawkins Lab. Earlier I alluded
to the demodogs sharing a hive mind.
The term hive mind comes from a hive of bumble
bees. The queen bee emits specific hormones to
help coordinate the female workers and the male
drones. The hive mind allows information about
water or pollen is located to be shared to
the entire hive to make them more efficient.
The demodogs use a combination of sounds to
alert each other, and their “queen” is a colossal
creature known as the Mind Flayer. The Mind
Flayer also has a special connection with Will,
essentially making him part of the hive mind. By
using Will to recognize where his friends were
located, the Mind Flyer sent a group of demodogs
to hunt them down, so Mike has the idea to sedate
him to prevent him from communicating with them.
As a result of this, the demodogs actually have
to search for their victims, giving them
all time to move to the the security room.
With the entire lab taken over by demodogs,
the group decides they need to perform a system
reboot to reactivate the door locks. They send
a man named Bob Newby down to the breaker room.
He arrives there and finds that every
lab employee in there has already been
ripped to shreds by the creatures. He
is able to successfully restart the lab,
but his friends find he is now trapped by a
demodog that moved into the west stairwell.
This, in addition to the pack using a decoy
against Steve Harrington earlier speaks
to the intelligence of these creatures.
They’re not just like bumblebee drones,
essentially following orders and
instinctually devouring prey.
They seem to realize that the lights going on
means there’s someone back in the breaker room.
Bob’s able to divert this dog using a noise
created by the sprinkler system and get away
as the others quietly move to the exit.
At this point, the pack splits up to more
effectively search the grounds, which leads to
him getting caught. He manages to outrun one,
but it’s calls to the rest of the pack
allow them to quickly swarm the door,
break it down and take Bob
as their midnight snack.
They probably would have been better
off with that 3 Musketeers Bar though.
– "Big on chocolate, Not on fat!"
– Chief Hopper tries to shoot them down,
but they’re also bulletproof. Luckily,
they’re too engrossed in their meal to care.
Everyone has regroups at the Byers’ house,
where they have their realization
about the hive mind and determine
the best way to beat the army of demodogs is
to destroy the shadow monster, which acts as
the brain of this superorganism. They try
to question Will in an ambiguous location,
but The Mind Flayer is still able to find out
where they are and send the demodogs their way.
Just as the first one shows up, so does the
completely overpowered psychokinetic girl, Eleven.
She snaps its neck and tosses it
through the Byers’ window for some
reason. That’s actually kind of
rude and I hope she pays for it.
The group splits up for a plan to try to break
the Mind Flayer’s influence on Will by closing
the gate to the Upside Down, where a massive
horde of demodogs is now festering. Steve,
Mike, Dustin, Max and Lucas stay at the house.
After putting the dead demodog in the
Byers’s freezer for… scientific purposes…
–  [Steve] You’re explaining this to Mrs. Byers, alright?
– [Zac] ...they realize they can use the hive mind to
their advantage by creating a
distraction so that the dogs…
– [Dustin] Demodogs!
– [Zac] ...so that the demodogs are
drawn away from the lab,
thus creating an easier path for Eleven to get
to the gate to the Upside-Down and destroy it.
They plan to do this by starting
a fire in the underground tunnels.
Using Will’s map, they locate the area that
they think is the main hub where all the
upside down tentacle things are and cover it
with gasoline. Steve lights the area on fire,
which causes a great deal of pain
to those tentacles, and as a result,
every creature that is part of the hivemind.
The demodogs at the gate all go crazy, and
the Mind Flayer prioritizes putting a stop
to the fire, so they all clear out of the gate
area. As Steve and the kids run for the exits,
they come face to face with none other than Dart.
(screech)
– Dart...
(impact)
(synth music)
With the hub now on fire, Dart’s newest
task was to take out any danger to the pack.
By following the sounds of Dustin’s group,
Dart was the first to track them down and face
the boy who betrayed him less than 36 hours
ago. Let’s just play it back one more time.
(screech)
They slowly approach each other,
and the two share a moment where Dustin apologizes
for knocking Dart into the cellar and offers a 3
Musketeers to smooth things over and distract
him long enough for everyone else to sneak by.
There are a couple of notable things
about this scene. The first is that
the Mind Flayer doesn’t seem to have as much
control over Dart as it has over the others,
as Dart is still able to
make decisions on his own.
The second is that it almost seems like Dart
is wired differently than the others, having
developed a greater taste for chocolate than it
has for human flesh. Maybe Dart associates that
taste with its youth, the same way that we
always have a preference for Mom’s home cooking.
In the end, D’artagnan chose to eat the 3
Musketeers rather than following the Mind
Flayer’s orders, and in that sense, he lived
up to his namesake from the 3 Musketeers novel.
One of the central themes of the novel is
this idea of all-for-one vs. one-for-all
and d’Artagnan is
forced to decide between being a
King’s musketeer or part of his group
of friends known as the inseparables.
In Stranger Things, loyalty to the hivemind
represents the idea of one-for-all,
but loyalty to his friend Dustin, who took him in
and fed him early on is an example of all-for-one.
Despite Dustin’s repeated insistence that a
demodog is not a dog, their final meeting is
reminiscent of the saying goodbye to
a beloved pet trope. Demodog or not,
Dart was a good pet and friend to Dustin.
When Eleven closes the gate, the Mind Flayer is
cut off from its hosts and Dart falls with the
rest of the demodog army. With his army dead,
the Mind Flayer is forced to retreat, but that
doesn’t mean he’s defeated. But that’s a
story for another episode of Horror History.
Hopefully this analysis helps add some context
to the coordination of the demodogs and their
life cycle. And by the way, let me know who else
you’d like to see covered here on Horror History,
or what franchise you’d like to see me cover.
Checkout that playlist on the left for more
Stranger Bois and remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell for notifications and I’ll see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(upbeat music)